[Música]
cerca de marsella la escalón que
conforman un macizo montañoso de relieve
atormentado
este espacio natural único se volvió el
décimo parque nacional de francia en el
[Música]
desde entonces de toda una población se
moviliza para proteger este litoral tan
mágico como frágil
durante cada estación los guardas en
monitores del parque forman jóvenes en
materia del servicio cívico 7 aquí es un
lugar que sirve casi de parqueadero y
pues vemos estos hábitats de interés
pensados quijote jugar que tiene swap
ale para que todo eso para la víctima ya
sea por peatones o por vehículos y al
frente se ve el impacto de los
estacionamientos sobre la vegetación o
la vegetación esta zona la más árida de
francia oculta sin embargo una flora
excepcional estos habitantes de marsella
que vienen aquí desde su infancia
siempre han visto estas plantas
desconociendo el valor que representan a
nivel nacional y como se encuentran aquí
en alguna medida son sus tesoros esto
personalmente me motiva más para hacer
mi trabajo para sensibilizar a la gente
descubrimos algo extraordinario uno nos
espera esto llegando o saliendo de
marsella
la misión de los guardas monitores se
desarrolla tanto en el mar como en la
tierra
varias zonas en la escalón que son
protegidas
los guardas del parque nacional
patrullan diariamente para disuadir a
los cazadores furtivos
más allá de estas boyas la pesca está
prohibida
la persona que pesca aquí le está
robando un poco a todo el mundo tal como
si robaron banco es aquí en un recurso
que todo el mundo trata de protegerse y
fausto lo protege
para proteger la vegetación submarina
está prohibido a lanzar el ancla pero
algunos turistas cometen dicha
infracción contractual de chrome o la
parque nacional de la escalón co están
ubicados en una zona prohibida lo sé
pero es culpa del viento de lo contrario
no me sostenga no me interesa salga de
la zona prohibida
[Música]
es una misión como de policía que nos
toma 40 por ciento del tiempo de los
guardias monitores
casa cultiva negligencia incivilidad es
inevitable desde que las k lonko atraen
a dos millones de visitantes cada año
pero el gran peligro es el fuego
hace cinco años un incendio accidental
se llevó 300 hectáreas del parque
nacional de la escalón coma
redondo
acababa de llegar a mi domicilio me
avisaron desde el cuartel y regresé para
tomar el volante del vehículo que
comandaba es un mal recuerdo porque a la
vegetación le costará volver a salir
yo nací en marsella me encanta pasear no
tengo ganas de ver un paisaje lunar
este cuartel está en primera línea
frente al macizo todos lo saben tienen
una gran responsabilidad
el terreno de intervención de los
bomberos de marsella se extiende sobre
40 kilómetros de costas sinuosas y rocas
hostiles
y para estar operativos en cualquier
situación con frecuencia organizan
ejercicios de salvamento tal como hoy
el escenario ocuparse de una víctima a
60 metros de altura
ya vi
[Música]
intervenciones frecuentes en el verano
cuando los adeptos a escalar sobre
estiman sus capacidades
a veces hay personas que subestiman el
aspecto de las montañas
creen estar en paredes lisas con buenos
equipos pero no esa selva principal
con la llegada masiva de los turistas en
el verano los accidentes son frecuentes
los bomberos deben hacerle frente a un
deceso al año por lo menos
al anochecer los guardas del parque
nacional buscan los frailecillos cenizos
una especie de ave protegida que se
reproduce cada año en estas rocas
este polluelo de 3 meses empezará a
volar en unos cuantos días pero antes de
ello
la ley le pone un anillo voy fiscalmente
pakistán comentando hay que dejar que se
calme
pero ahora se llamará 607 99 antes
este anillo permitirá identificarlo
dentro de algunos años cuando regrese a
marsella para reproducirse
así los naturalistas pueden hacerle
seguimiento a la especie año tras año
[Música]
puede participar en la protección
es una responsabilidad un honor y un
gusto
el día culmina con la sensación de una
misión cumplida
pero la protección de la naturaleza es
una apuesta a largo plazo y para los
centinelas de la escalón con nada
termina realmente
así